but I did see that that proposed trade
between the Brewers and Dodgers yasiel
Puig and Ryan Braun may still be on the
table there Bob Nightengale the USA
Today baseball writer had the column
today Bob good morning thanks for
joining us where do we stand with the
likelihood that these two guys could
still be traded for one another yeah
they were so close to having it done and
they had Ryan Braun wedding in the
clubhouse at one point every thought it
was done just couldn't agree in that
last prospect so no reason it won't be
revisited you know then Braun goes to LA
he lives right there in Malibu one of
the teams that's not his no-trade clause
Dodgers are able to dump Puig in the in
Brandon McCarthy as well along with a
couple of prospects so the two sides
that will revisit in the winter and no
reason why I can't get done during the
winter where did it go south for yasiel
Puig I just think is added to the
clubhouse just rubbed everybody the
wrong way I mean Don Mattingly you know
really have problems with him and the
coaching staff the players did you know
so far he's been his best behavior which
can only you know make the Brewers or
any bells you know happier that ok you
know maybe he's not a complete cancer in
the clubhouse it is almost like a guy be
his best behavior here in September or
else you know both set him back to the
minor leagues and he will have no chance
to be in a playoff roster but I thought
he had enough talent to maybe kind of
supersede this is he still is it the
potential being a great player is it
still there but just was still there is
she a lot of questions whether he'll
realize that potential in the you know
he's going to have a better work ethic
to and that was a problem you know
showing up late for batting practice and
meetings and think his talent would just
carry on in with you know baseball at
the mill and grind and everything else
it wasn't happening for him so I think
the Dodgers you know even though he's
playing well since it came back up and
you know they've had enough of them and
I be you know I think you and I have a
better chance of playing right so for
the Dodgers next year than Preakness
give me an update on what the Dodgers
can expect out of
Kershaw on the playoffs the big test is
what he does here his last three starts
you know they need to get that pitch
count up innings up to make sure he's
sharp if he is you know then the you
know then they have a very good chance
to you know play deep into October if
not november without them I think they
have no chance obviously they're gonna
make the playoffs BTW any Kershaw and
out that rotation they event you know
yeah my head in there Rich Hill showed
the town he has the him a fighting
chance if the Cubs of the favorites
who's the second favorite I could go
Washington Nationals just with Scherzer
on top of that rotation you know if they
could have Strasburg do Dan and I give
up powerful one-two punch but I think
that you know i mean the cubs right now
are just a heavy heavy favorites i think
the biggest shocker of all if we don't
see the cubs in the World Series I think
they're that good that complete of a
team go to visit with you Bob thanks for
joining us my pleasure thank Bob
Nightengale USA Today baseball writer
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience